In all fairness.
Uh,
what I used to see,
and I saw this many times at Nick's,
was some poor fuck who had led a couple of TV credits,
who thought he was hot shit and they would go on and they would headline at
Nick's and they would stack the deck and it would be horrendous.
It was you and Lenny and fucking Knox and all these savages would go up and
Boston style comedy where there's no breaks.
It's just fucking Bang,
Bang.
Right?
Yeah.
There's a style of comedy,
like a,
Hey,
I know you worked all day.
You don't want to hear anybody bullshitting up here.
Everybody talks fast and they're fucking funny.
And Gavin would go up and murder and then these poor bastards would go up after
them and just these people with their TV credits,
you would see them just be within five minutes,
they'd be lost.
It'd be very observational.
Have you ever gone to an airport?
What did just don't expect that they would see three worldclass headliners do 15
minutes in front of us.
Tell you a funny story about next
Sam Kennison,
right?
He,
you know,
he had been up for a few days obviously,
but anyway,
you know what I mean?
You know the era.
So I said s and Sam was a good friend of mine.
He's a nice guy.
When he was straight,
he had a dark side,
you know,
like we all do.
But I said,
Sam,
this isn't,
this isn't la.
You know,
these guys,
you know Joey the job and bully the frond and fault.
You know what I mean?
This sitting up front and he's,
you know how Sam was and I said,
Sam,
I'm telling you these are the wrong guys to piss off.
They had to fire him because you know,
those guys don't kill it.
They don't.
They don't have any sense of humor.
No.
Well,
not only that,
they don't,
they don't want to be fucked with.
Yeah.
Boston's.
So one of the weird,
some of the weirdest people in terms of like the way the rest of the world
works,
they're ready to fight.
There's a lot of people that are ready to fight though,
ready to fight you.
They're not going to shoot you or stab you.
They're going to beat the fuck out of you,
right.
They're going to do it right then and there and it'll,
it'll happen anywhere.
It'll happen at a restaurant or happen at a bar is one of the last places that
we,
when we used to towards him ready to break out what you would see real fist
fights like all the time.
Like Ari Shaffir used to say that like me and him while we're leaving Faneuil
hall once and there was a fucking brawl breaking out in front of this Mcdonald's
and he's like,
you fucking people are savages here.
I'm like,
I'm telling you,
it's a different kind of human.
It's cold for too much.
The women are assholes.
Like it's,
the men are assholes.
Everybody's ready to fight and everyone's drunk.
It's a different kind of place.
Well,
you know the,
I grew up in Charleston,
right?
They did a movie about the town and all that bull shit.
It's a bullshit movie.
But anyway,
I grew up over there and you didn't have to win,
but you had a fight.
And my record was probably
two wins and 30 losses.
And then to,
you know,
there's a lot of draws because they break it up right away,
you know.
But there were actual fist fights.
Yeah.
No.
One time I'm in the projects is kid Davey ladder.
He did the one thing you're not supposed to do.
He kicked me in the balls and then everybody jumped and beat the shit out of
him.
The one thing about kicking people in the balls to don't ever mess.
Yeah.
Cause then the other guy gets very mad.
It doesn't work as good as people think.
It does.
Don't release.
It hurts now will you in street fights.
I started fighting to avoid street fights.
I wanted to fight like is it as an amateur like in martial arts tournaments
because I was scared of street fights while they seem to me,
it seemed to me to a are frightened and he fucking terrifying.
You never know what's going to happen.
People follow you around.
You never know when it's going to.
I was scared of fighting.
That's why I got into it.
I was,
I just,
I did not like to remember that day when you were in grammar school and a kid
offers you out.
Yeah.
At eight 30 in the morning and still thinking about it all day early in the
morning till three in the afternoon own.
What's that?
Running down your pants.
Did you just shit yourself here and then you're in the school yard and they're
all circling around you,
you know,
and it's this whole thing.
But my father used to train fighters,
boxers over at the new guard and Jim and me and my brother,
we would get into terrible fights and my father never taught us how to throw a
shot or anything.
It just gives us these big enormous fricking gloves and they just let you go to
war on each other.
Yeah,
it was weird.
Why did he teach you?
Probably tired from teaching people all day.
Yeah,
maybe.
it's probably,
maybe he wanted us to beat the shit out of each other,
you know?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
I've not gone to figure it out on your own.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I remember coming back and,
um,
this kid beat the shit out of me.
Bobby Buckley and my father said,
what are you doing at home?
You got to go back out there.
What?
I'm going to go back out and fight him again.
Fucking all right.
Yeah.
But I,
you know,
there's a lot of different ways to be like in Charlestown grown up.
I mean I was,
I grew up with some guys that were like unbelievable.
Like,
you know,
there's a,
there's a whole moral thing maybe or a social thing about say robbing a bank.
I mean,
would that ever fricking cross your mind?
No,
but that's a Charles town thing.
That's one thing that is true about that movie,
that town,
but,
but what I was in awe of people that would do it.
It's like,
where do you get the boss that you know?
And I'll never forget this friend of mine,
Joey Rocco's no longer with us.
So I see him up at government ember.
You remember government center?
Yeah.
So I see them up there and he's got like his lunch and I said,
Joe,
how you doing?
And he's kind of blew me off.
Then I see him a week later.
He says,
say Swayne's,
what's up?
I said,
You blew me off a week ago.
He said,
Oh,
I'm so sorry.
I was waiting to Rob Crimson travel and I had my gun there and I was into was
interrupting his work.
So he came into Nick's comedy,
stopped to 400 people.
I did fantastic.
I was like practically a standing ovation,
whatever.
So Joe's in the audience,
right.
And I,
I,
so I talked to him afterwards.
So there's a number of things he could say like,
Jeez,
I liked his show.
I didn't like your show.
Good for you.
Getting out at Charlestown.
He gave me this look.
I was like,
wow,
it's got to be a lot of money in here.
I said,
you think I'm here to case the joint for you?
It was unbelievable.
We used to,
I'm part of the thing that bugged Charlestown,
grown up with see how to shoplift that was,
did you do that when you were a kid?
Like,
shit,
I got caught shoplifting.
Candy,
candy.
Yeah,
you were bad.
You probably was terrified right.
Again to God.
I got brought into a manager's office,
I think it was 12.
Oh yeah,
I got in trouble.
I was terrible too.
I was so paranoid.
But anyway,
there was a department store called Jordan Marsh and my job was to catch a
football.
They throw me the football,
I'd catch it and run down Tremont street.
So we've just,
you know,
stolen a football.
Right.
So that's,
that was the Gig.
So one time I'm up there and uh,
saw the kid says to me,
pick up the end of this canola.
I said what?
He said grab the end of the cannula still in a fucking canoes was all walking
down.
Wash the student Boston with a condo right now I don't know where you're from
but it's not a big item and Charlestown canoes and the projects,
you know what I mean?
It's like not something that you felt you couldn't fence it.
Did you take it to the Charles River?
I don't know what we did with it.
Like you'd do try to,
you end up either giving it away as selling it for like three bucks.
Cause that was back then that the river was very,
very dirty.
Like I used to swim in that.
Oh,
that was the,
uh,
well we used to call the oilies because there was so much oil in it.
Yeah.
And better now though,
right?
Didn't they clean it up a little bit?
That's what they say.
You know,
they made,
they've cleaned up the whole of Boston.
I don't recognize boss anymore.
They've got this pot of Boston called the sea port.
It's all these big buildings.
It's like fricking Dubai,
you know,
there's no kids,
there's no neighborhoods,
there's no characters.
It's all just gentrified in a very rich people now.
Right.
Yeah,
I apparently,
yeah.
What is it like bankers who,
who's got all that money?
I,
that's what I keep asking myself.
Who,
who does have all this money?
Yeah.
Boston is definitely,
but la is the same way.